non un élément vital pour l'être humain
60% notre corps est composé d'eau donc
vivant de tous les jours et sept matches
derrière moi évoque certainement pour
vous la santé la vie l'eau minérale
ressources longues et descendre montagne
en fait avoir accès à l'eau potable
c'est pas forcément simple bonne partie
de la planète n'a pas accès à ces
défauts parce que c'est pas si simple
derrière ce geste simple mais le robinet
g servir un verre d'eau se cache un
processus relativement complexe qui
commence ici dans le milieu naturel de
l'eau dans les zones urbaines standard
on commence par capter l'eau dans les
nappes phréatiques dans les souks dont
les rivières
et puis cette eau est emmené vers
morzine de traitement when will voiture
est rendue potable
on va éventuellement rajouter les agents
pour qu'elle reste potable pour un
certain temps
ensuite elle doit être stocké dans des
réservoirs ont des châteaux d'eau et
puis à l'epad mis à votre disposition à
la demande
ensuite une fois que vous aurez consommé
l'eau les oliviers vous la connaissez et
puis amené vers une station d'épuration
voile va être encore nettoyer été remis
dans son milieu naturel pour parcourir
ce cycle l'eau doit se déplacer et cela
elle veut pas le faire naturellement on
doit apporter de l'énergie à l'eau ou
qu'elles puissent circuler le long de ce
site
et pour le faire on va utiliser ce qu'on
appelle une bombe alors comment ça
marche
en fait pour entraîner de l'eau on va
utiliser des eaux
une double à 2 dans ce cas là donc ses
roues qui sont en rotation va entraîner
l'eau qui va se
as des platines pour tourner sierre où l
on donne un moteur et ce modèle qui
fonctionne il a bien d'électricité
autrement dit pour que son maître l'eau
potable
en fait vous consommez l'électricité
maintenant pour les vandales iard pour
les gens qui habitent par exemple ici
emballé on a la chance parce que l'eau
se trouve dans son millionnaire d'une
aile en montagne on a des sources en
altitude ce qui fait qu'on peut faire
cette étape captage en altitude
ensuite mettre l'euro sous pression dans
une conduite année c'est toujours vers
une usine de filtration ensuite vers un
château d'eau où on a un réservoir de
stockage et puis ensuite astra miel à
votre disposition
la grosse différence avec le cycle de
tout à l'heure c'est que là l'ol peut
s'écouler naturellement
alors pourquoi est ce qu'elle peut
s'écouler naturellement parce qu'elle a
une énergie hydraulique alors l'énergie
hydraulique ses voix pour simplifier un
petit peu dans ce cas-là l'énergie hydro
lille c'est l'énergie potentielle que
l'eau possède dans ce cas les uns
aptitudes une fois qu'on fait cette
étape de mettre pause dans la conduite
pour la vigne et verdi de filtration on
va transférer cette énergie le potentiel
en énergie cinétique
c'est à dire je redonne un mouvement à
l'eau une énergie de pression et la
pression de l'eau qui va augmenter
puisque l'eau descend la pression dans
le augmenté aussi contre les parois de
la canalisation
il y aura à l'énergie potentiel résiduel
et puis aux rosiers faire parce que
quand l'eau se débat dans une conduite
il ya du froid devant au niveau de la
paroi regroupe un peu d'énergie
le problème souvent c'est cette énergie
pression parce que plus le descend plus
la pression de la pression monte la
pression massive verser sur les parois
de la canalisation qui rist dossier
et puis on aura des fuites et des
problèmes prenons un exemple standard on
aurait milieux naturels qui se trouve à
900 mètres d'altitude
les conservateurs à 500 m ça veut dire
si on fait un petit calcul qu'on aurait
une énergie potentielle à disposition
bout 400 m chip aussi supposons qu'une
partie cette énergique parts dans
l'énergie cinétique les vertes qui va
nous rester une énergie de passion de
200 m le problème c'est que dans les
canalisations d'eau christique de votre
maison
on veut pas supporter une pression
supérieure à 50 mètres du coup on va
devoir dissiper l'énergie de pression
dissiper l'énergie hydraulique en
chaleur
pour ça on va utiliser un réducteur de
pression parce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que du bon disciple de l'énergie
alors là on pourrait se poser une
question tout à l'heure on avait un
cycle fermé
on était obligés d'apporter de l'énergie
à l'eau on est obligé de consommer
l'électricité pour la faire circuler et
puis la halle où elle descend tout seul
et en fait elle a trop d'énergie en
utilisant dissiper donc la question
qu'on peut se poser c'est est ce qu'on
peut pas la récupérer cette énergie
en fait oui un peu on va faire en fait
le parcours inverse tout à l'heure on
utilise non pas une pompe mais une
turbine
alors qu'est ce que c'est une turbine
non en fait c'est simplement une roue
qui est entraînée par l'eau qui se
déplacent naturellement qui augmente
cette roue qui tourne elle va entraîner
ce qu'on appelle un générateur qui va
produire de l'électricité
ce qui fait qu'en fait dans ce cas là
quand vous allez oust sommet de l'eau
potable
vous avez produire de l'électricité
c'est quand même nettement différente
alors pour vous donner quelques ordres
de grandeur en fait en suisse le plat le
turbinage de beaux tops ça existe déjà
depuis de nombreuses années en
particulier en valais puis cette
production d'électricité en représente
la consommation d'environ 15 minutes
mais les agents suisses puisque
intéressant c'est qu'il ya encore un
grand potentiel sur les réseaux d'eau
potable
en général on utilise des turbines
peleton que vous aimiez un petit dessin
si vous en avez peut-être déjà vu
souvent on est plus grande dans les
grandes usines hydroélectriques qu'on a
ici
à bieudron par exemple bah non en fait
dire qu'il quitte pour les réseaux d'eau
potable parce que les puissants sont
plus faibles
beaucoup de dissiper l'énergie ont
produit l'électricité avec ses machines
le problème c'est que dans certaines
situations les consommateurs se situe
relativement proche du milieu naturel ce
qui veut dire en fait on a une énergie
potentielle qui est pas très importante
dans ces cas là la turbine peleton ne
fonctionne pas donc la question qu'on
peut se poser c'est est ce qu'on peut
pas trouver un nouveau système vous
puisse continuer à produire de
l'électricité 20 sur les réseaux d'eau
potable où il ya un peu moins d'énergie
alors c'est ce qu'on a décidé de faire
la chasse aux baleines en collaboration
avec universal et puis trois entreprises
valaisannes
vous avez peut-être lu occasion de voir
derrière cette machine à l'espace
innovation tout à l'heure donc c'est une
petite turbine qui en fait elle était
complètement développé à la jeunesse
dans le bfr voyez ici la construction de
l'art ou le design hydraulique
cette turbine est proposé de deux roues
qui tourne la sens contraire qu'ils vont
ensuite être disposés dans un tuyau dans
une canalisation que vous voyez ici
en fait dans le petit cylindre au centre
de la tempête se trouve la génératrice
qui vont produire l'électricité
on a fait un premier prototype pour
l'attester au laboratoire des chaussées
souvent l'air et puis on est en train de
tester les performances de cette machine
décider les résultats sont concluants en
installera cette machine sur un site
pilote qui situe sur la commune de
savièse
alors prenons maintenant un petit peu de
recul par rapport à cette production
d'électricité en fait en suisse hydro
d'expliciter ses environs 56% à la
production d'électricité
on a aussi un beau nucléaire 38 % et
puis l'électricité qui provient de
l'éolien et le solaire ils sont
relativement faibles et
et et buté sur ce terme alors sur les 56
% d'hydre les précités il y en a 5 % qui
sont produits par la petite
hydroélectricité c'est à dire des
centrales de petite puissance inférieure
à 10 mégawatts et ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'il y ait encore un grand
potentiel parce que construire les
grands barrages en suisse on va
peut-être essayé mais elle est
compliquée parce qu'un impact sur
l'environnement qui alors que pour la
petite hydraulique en a un fort
potentiel et on peut limiter cet impact
par exemple en installant des turbines
sur les réseaux d'eau potable puisque
c'est une infrastructure existante
on a juste à venir découpé un morceau de
tuyau venir mettra sur bin et à produire
l'électricité
donc pour conclure ce soir vous avez
compris que vous êtes peut-être dans la
situation où lorsque vous vous servez un
verre de la maison indirectement vous
produisez l'électricité qui sert gotten
à alimenter la batterie de votre natel
mais ne s'était pas les étapes